Loretta napoleoni is author of insurgent
Iraq al Zarqawi and the new generation
published by seven stories press on the
web at seven stories dot-com former NATO
ambassador and special counselor to the
president David Abshire recounts his
involvement in the iran-contra affair in
his book saving the Reagan presidency
this talk from Texas A&M University in
College Station is just over an hour I'm
delighted to welcome you tonight tonight
we feature the ConocoPhillips lecture
series on White House the Conoco lecture
White House lecture series to be more
specific this series focuses on the
various offices within the White House
as well as organizations and groups that
deal with the White House the purpose of
the program is to bring to the general
public's attention the role of the men
women as well as the offices that deal
with the White House and as well as of
the office itself before we get into
tonight's program I'd like to first of
all thank ConocoPhillips for its support
in making this program possible and
tonight we have a number of
representatives all the way from Houston
that have given up going to the Houston
Astros game to join us here tonight so I
I would really appreciate a real round
of support for them
and I would like to take the pleasure to
introduce them Clara Bradley who is the
director corporate contributions and
ConocoPhillips please stand Lara
Campbell directed downstream
communications laura hopkins senior
specialist finance and communication
catherine strong exploration director
[Applause]
and mia brown advisor and recruiting
ladies once again thank you for joining
us
i'd also like to acknowledge miss Becky
gates wife of the president of Texas A&M
University dr. Robert Gates Becky as
usual thank you and Bob's running a
little late but he should join us
shortly ambassador David Abshire is
president of the Center for the Study of
the presidency in Washington DC and also
president of the Richard Lounsbury
foundation of New York he is vice
chairman of the board of the Center for
Strategic and International Studies in
Washington DC which he co-founded David
is a 1951 graduate of West Point and
later received his doctorate with honors
in history from Georgetown University
dr. a prior served as assistant
secretary of state for congressional
relations from 1970 to 1973 and later is
the first chairman of the u.s. Board of
International broadcasting he was a
member of the Murphy Commission on the
organization of the government and the
president's foreign intelligence by
Advisory Board in 1983 through 1987 he
was ambassador to NATO we're in reaction
to the threat posed by Soviet ss-20
missiles
he was the United States point man in
Europe for develop deployment of
Pershing and cruise missiles it was this
NATO success that convinced the Soviets
to sign the historic INF treaty and
withdraw their missiles ambassador
Abshire initiated a new conventional
defense improvement effort so that NATO
would not have to rely heavily on
nuclear weapons for this he was given
the highest Defense Department civilian
award his distinguished public service
in December 1986 at the depths of the
iran-contra crisis he was called by
President Reagan to leave NATO serving
the cabinet and help restore confidence
in the presidency he dealt with the
tower board the Independent Counsel and
the congressional investigation
committees dr. Abshire is the author of
six books including his latest saving
the Reagan presidency he's married to
the former Carolyn sample and they have
five children
dr. Abshire will speak for approximately
30 minutes tonight after which you'd be
happy to take questions from the
audience those of you who would like to
address the question to dr. abstract can
do so by using the microphones that are
positioned in the middle aisles for the
front of the auditorium as a conclusion
of our program we will have a reception
for all the attendees of tonight's
program in the lobby as well as a book
signing those of you who like to pick up
a copy of dr. after his latest book may
do so and he'll be happy to sign it on a
personal note I'd like to state that I
had the pleasure and the honor of
working with dr. Chari during the time
that he was in working with President
Reagan it was a real experience I found
them to be very dedicated to public
service a real professional and a joy to
work with ladies and gentlemen please
give a warm welcome to dr. David Abshire
[Applause]
I'm delighted to be here and to deliver
this ConocoPhillips White House lecture
I'm particularly delighted to be with my
friend and colleague ambassador Roman
Papa do you know I know I don't know
that I could have gotten through those
three difficult months without his first
profound knowledge of the press which we
dealt with daily and he was our liaison
to the brass a second he had the best
knowledge in depth in digging into this
iran-contra situation and third he had
an extraordinary sense of humor right at
the right time when we we all needed it
so I'm in his debt
I'm also happy to be back at the George
HW Bush library I have co-chaired
several programs down here the most
impressive was with the former President
Bush in the year 2000 when I turned over
CSI as two other hands and took over the
Center for the Study of the presidency
we examined all interventions going back
to Eisenhower's non-intervention in 1954
and we did this with the Kennedy School
in the the bush library and and George
HW Bush talked to about not only experts
but 400 students we have without notes
about the decision-making process in
going into the Gulf War and his
decision-making process the care with
which was taken and the execution of
that was a masterpiece but to hear him
describe it was was really extraordinary
and as I walked through with my young
colleague max anger Holmes who this
afternoon
once again the the Bush memorandum
recalled his heroism in
in World War two and the other
courageous things in his life I think
he's a model for for young people across
the country so it's great to be back
here now iran-contra is a morality play
it's a tragedy and a deep tragedy that
ended in a triumph and that's the kind
of morality plays we like not those that
start with the triumph that ends in a
tragedy so the end of the story is is
redeeming and but you've got to
understand the depth of the crisis that
we found ourselves in to then understand
the greatness of Ronald Reagan's break
out of that crisis as NATO ambassador
and far away from Washington one of my
briefs in 1984 85 and 86 was to scold
allies that might send arms to Iran
which was on the list of terrorist
Nations and George Shultz had instituted
what is called Operation staunch and
this was something where we as leader of
the Alliance were propagating a doctrine
to others that they should not violate
so it was a bombshell on November 3rd
1986 when in a Lebanese periodical
al-sharia it comes out that the United
States has been selling arms to Iran and
that furthermore later it comes out this
was an attempt to trade arms for
hostages
it was simply inconceivable that this
had happened and the president initially
denied it because his advisers convinced
him that the the lives of hostages were
at stake and they should have a cover
story
there had been an attempt to to deal
with the Hezbollah movement part of the
Shiite movement that is still in in in
Lebanon and Syria and despite the
initial denials it comes out very soon
that in September 1985 we had sent 504
tows tubelaunch wire guided anti-tank
missiles to Iran which was in in a war
with Iraq and we had publicly said we
were neutral the problem with Ronald
Reagan himself he considered trading
arms for hostages to be immoral and he
couldn't conceive that he had been led
into trading arms for hostages John
Wayne didn't do that they didn't do that
in the West and he felt you would be
taken if you did that and by the way
that's exactly what was happened because
in these trades we never got to send my
hostages back we get one back more were
taken we were had but he had a naive
idea that we were dealing with one group
in Beirut and another group in Iran and
that didn't make it arms for hostages
and in this crisis that developed over
the the coming weeks
and I'm at NATO at this point reading
the newspapers comes the real bombshell
and that is at lieutenant-colonel north
operating out of the executive office
building had been involved in a covert
deal of delivering of attempting to
deliver the profits from inflated arms
sales to the Contras fighting the
Marxist the anti Sandinistas forces
opposing the Nicaraguan regime now this
is a violation of the Constitution
article 1 section on no money should be
drawn from the Treasury
but in consequences of appropriation by
law also against any deficiency Act
which would make it a felony and when
when the Attorney General ed Meese broke
this news to the president those
presents say that the the blood drained
from his face he immediately knew the
consequences of this never could be
proven that the president knew it was it
was an impeachable offense Evans and
Novak wrote a column saying the Reagan
presidency was dead
now it's ambassador NATO made up of 16
sovereign nations Ronald Reagan was a
leader of the Alliance and we were at a
key point in the Cold War the Reykjavik
meeting had broken up and we know now
that Reagan in standing his ground and
not giving up the Strategic Defense
Initiative that this was a turning point
but it but it appeared to be an enormous
setback and so our president was down
and in deep trouble
and Gorbachev was on the move so the
morality play is very dramatic at the
point that the hero is down partly of
his own doing not knowing what Ollie
north and others had done but
nevertheless he had created the climate
and it allowed this to happen you know
in this part of my life I've devoted a
lot of it to studying presidential
leadership in general and leadership in
general and I say in talking to young
people we can all get in a hole if you
live life if you take make big moves you
are going to get into a hole you are
going to make mistakes the test of
character
is not it never making a mistake and
that's not in never getting into a hole
it's what you do when you're in it
whether you dig it deeper or whether you
get out and this is true in presidential
history and its truths and
businesspeople look at these CEOs some
going to jail we we see it a character
of crisis throughout America because
some don't know how to deal with that
with character Woodrow Wilson as he went
to Versailles and and negotiated an
agreement where he was partly taken by
climb on so in a way he was he was in a
hole there and didn't recognize that he
went back and didn't take any
Republicans didn't have any bipartisan
coalition and then tried to go around to
Congress and he got in a hole and ended
up a broken man and we didn't have a
treaty we didn't have the very sign
agreement which might have prevented a
Hitler and Stalin Nixon didn't know
about Watergate five days after that
break-in he comes back to Washington and
he leads the obstruction of of Justice
Clinton in the Lewinsky affair if he'd
gotten in some advisor other than Dick
Morris but some some wise advisor they
would have said get it all out the
country would have been disgusted for
two weeks and the nation's business
would have moved on seems so simple
we've got problems today
these same principles apply to
presidential leadership now the name of
my book is who saved is is saving the
Reagan presidency who saved the Reagan
presidency first the President himself
he had the character when he was deep in
to make the breakout not right away
he helped dig it a little deeper
for a bit but then he made the breakout
and he did that when the the revelations
of Colonel North's rogue operation to
divert funds from arms to hostages was
so serious that he had to break through
of these advisors and they they fired an
appoint actor and Colonel north but we
had a problem because the the chief of
staff who did not know about this but he
had been portrayed as the prime minister
who knew everything Don Regan very
powerful individual so many people held
him responsible on December 26 1986 I
received a phone call at Truman Hall my
retina toe residence from the president
asking me to come back for three months
I had an obligation to go back to my
Center for teaching international
studies but he wanted me to come back
for three months as special counselor
report directly to him not through the
chief of staff be of cabinet rank and to
deal with the tower board which had been
set up to do a two months report and by
the way in my book I devote considerable
attention to the tower board operation
because it's something that could serve
this president well and other presidents
well when they got a problem a report
bipartisan where he had Senator John
tower Brent Scowcroft universally
admired and Senator muskie their very
evil staff to try to get to the bottom
of some of this because nobody knew the
truth Oliver North had done a lot of
shredding of documents that had been a
lot of lying that had gone on and so we
realized that that we had to have a
point of departure
to recalibrate where we were going he
said there would be no executive
privilege now I believe in executive
privilege in many circumstances you've
got to have executive privilege you have
it was a Supreme Court and the staff of
the court the Constitutional Convention
took place under executive privilege it
is it is a needed function of the
executive the confidentiality of the
executive branch but but Reagan and his
team recognized that this was so serious
there could be no executive privilege
that was an extraordinary happening in
American history to get it all out there
were 3,000 documents that the FBI had
noted that pertained to the iran-contra
affair any one of those could be a
smoking gun any one of those could have
been deeply embarrassing if not a
smoking gun get it all out that's what
he said over the phone that was my
function to work with the with the
investigators with Judge Walsh who had
been made the Independent Counsel the
the two committees in the Congress that
might take many months and then the the
tower board so the the bubble in the
White House was broken in this move not
completely cos Don Regan was still there
and every day the press was talking
about that and while Nancy Reagan was
very strong and feeling that you had to
have a complete suite the weakness of
this president a man of great compassion
he couldn't bring himself to put people
out when they should be put out now this
leads me to
the role of the first lady because in my
copy of this book to Nancy Reagan I
wrote in there something to the fact
that you turned out to be a great hero
and I didn't write it that way that's
the way the facts came out because she
was totally different from Edith Wilson
when Wilson had his stroke and when they
were maneuvers to work up something with
the White House she kept him in
isolation and she controlled everything
and Nancy Reagan was exactly the
opposite of that concerned about her
husband's place in history concerned
with breaking out she even at one point
before I came back had the former she
was so desperate because she felt the
president didn't understand the depth of
his problem that she had former attorney
general secretary of state bill Rodgers
and Robert Strauss former chairman of
the Democratic National Committee wise
man around Washington though brought in
through the secret passage not secret
now but the secret passage from Treasury
to the White House and taken up to the
residence to meet with the president and
she said when they got in there she said
mr. Rogers mr. Strauss I think the
president's in deep trouble and I felt
he should hear from some outsiders and
and Bill Rogers said well you know I I
don't know that this is so bad I think
maybe we're just weather this out if
some of these laws are they're not that
clear I think we'll make it mrs. Reagan
was devastated by the way I've heard
this stories three times from her I've
heard it five times from Braham Straus
gets better every time and because he's
very colorful he's a great friend of
mine
and then she called on mr. Strauss and
his Strauss later told me he said you
know they didn't even give me anything
to drink and I said Bob they know you
like your double scotches he said scotch
hell I didn't even get water and so she
said mr. stress what do you think
and he said looking at Ronald Reagan he
said well mr. president I was in here
with Lyndon Johnson as we were sort of
seats
sinking into a war of attrition with
light at the end of the tunnel and no
outside advice then he had about six
people in the room and he went around to
each one and we sort of knew what he
wanted he wanted consolation and they
all said well mr. president really not
that boy oh don't worry don't need to do
any kind of new assessment and said they
got to me and I was the six and he
looked at Ronald Reagan said you know
what I did mr. president I said the same
thing you don't have anything to worry
about but then he said looking at Reagan
he said you know that night I went out
on this White House long and I felt like
a $2.00 prostitute and he said mr.
president looking at Ronald Reagan I'm
not going out on that lawn a second time
feeling that way and he pulled out a
piece of paper and he you're in deep
trouble in other words somebody got to
the president with Nancy as a
facilitator the great Dean of
presidential historians Richard Neustadt
god bless him the last thing he wrote is
the introduction to my book he did it
very thoroughly he married Shirley named
Shirley Williamson and so he spent a lot
of his time not at Harvard there in his
latter years but in London and he's done
have done a very thorough analysis you
can we read his introduction maybe you
don't need to read the book but he
analyzes all parts of it but I had asked
him to do this because in his last
edition of the modern presidency he
talked about what he called the Nancy
factor that every president needs that
radar that ability to reach out he said
in Franklin Roosevelt and he's a great
student of Franklin Roosevelt said that
you had two elements first you had
Eleanor who was always reaching out but
second Roosevelt was gossipy he was
curious he talked to the press he wanted
to know the gossip called the people on
the hill Ronald Reagan wasn't that way
he was aloof and he was and curious so
particularly with him you needed what he
called the nancy factor eyes and ears
that could reach beyond the bubble in
the White House now Nancy saw me when I
came back the first time I met with her
a special counselor Ronald Don Regan and
this is where he was correct he wanted
because his survival was at stake he
realized that you had to bring in an
outside person and he felt that if you
know if you brought in an outside person
and sort of mr. a mr. clean as he put it
who had been involved in any of this
maybe this would get things off his back
and he would survive and maybe go on to
be chairman of the Federal Reserve or
something like that and it was it was
really pat buchanan the the director of
communications that wrote this memo that
we're sinking in more and more and you
need a special counts or somebody from
the outside that can report directly to
the president that can do all of this
coordination and take the weight off of
our back when I was first called Don
Regan called me in advance and let me
say Don Don Regan was an outstanding
Secretary of Treasury he was not
standing head of Merrill Lynch that's
when I first knew him it was a friend of
mine he simply was the wrong man to be
chief of staff to prayer
Ravin wrong man good man and other jobs
but the wrong man for that job but I
when I was told that they had decided on
me and that they would have a team of
lawyers and I felt to deal with judge
Walsh I needed my own deputy and I
brought in judge charge Charles Brower
so that I had my judge when we met with
with judge Brower and he had the job of
coordinating all the General Counsel's
in the processing of these 3,000
documents that were being sent to the
investigating committee each one
carefully classified on methods and
sources and protected and some kept down
here for the staff to see in some sent
to the hill and in my relationships with
judge Lawrence Walsh during this period
they were excellent
they were so good because he felt that
we were setting up a process that was
the the the the subtitle of my book is
Trust is the coin of the realm he says
you're you we're recreating a process a
two-track system a system in Plata in
place of flawed process due process and
he says I won't use subpoena power at
several years later he regretted that
and he became very sour later on and
this thing went on for seven years and
this is one of the drawbacks of an
independent counsels investigation when
they sort of miss their first targets
that they they keep going far beyond the
original mission but we in dealing we
had articles through Romans help in the
press where they began to say that we
had substituted due process for flawed
process and I got the Montreux trust is
the coin of the realm from I learned my
congressional relations when I was on
Capitol Hill as director the House
Republican policy committee that
a part of the Eisenhower period and
Bryce Harlow was the chief of staff to
to President Eisenhower and that was his
motto and he always sort of looked over
his head Trust is the coin of the rare
everybody trusted five-star Ike and
trust and credibility is the most sacred
characteristic of presidential
leadership and this was being restored
and it was being restored because Reagan
had made this basic decision and it's
interesting as compared to the Clinton
situation where there was such
partisanship on Capitol Hill that when I
went to Capitol Hill with with judge
Brower and I still carried the NATO
ambassadorship for period and the
Democrats that I dealt with CSIS was a
bipartisan institution and I built
bipartisan friendships but I would go in
and they would say David what's we can't
lose the leader of the Alliance we can't
have another Nixon situation they were
all during that three months pulling
together after my departure not because
of my departure but after the North
hearing everything got close to the
election everything became politicized
and we lost that but in that period
where we had the two-track procedure
where you had the counsel to the
president who had the job at the defense
of the president and my job was not the
defense of the president it was the
defense of the process that was the
secret of that comeback I had during
this period a dozen meetings alone with
the president I had about that many with
with Nancy Reagan and we worked towards
the reception of the tower board and we
then following that work towards the
comeback press conference where he
accepted full responsibility for what
had happened
the the marvelous writer Peggy Noonan
has written a book when character was
King on Ronald Reagan but she says that
iran-contra contained no hidden gifts no
lucky loss was bad from the beginning to
the end but once I disagree with Peggy
Noonan
character was above all keen in the way
that Reagan came back from his crisis
and the way he restored the glue of
presidential trusts he dug himself into
the hole he moved to get out of the hole
and from that he could move on to move
towards the end of the Cold War in great
triumph and this is in such penultimate
chapter of my book is the other two
presidents that didn't follow that
course both people of enormous talent
one whose presidency was destroyed and
the others who was hurt now my final by
the way just a word on anjaan judge
Walsh who in my dealings was impeccable
and later kept going and when the the
the initial convictions of of North and
Poindexter North for destroying NSC
documents false chronologies illegal
gratuities were overturned by the
appeals court because of immune eyes
congressional testimony that might have
tainted witnesses then Walsh in
is is a rapist
tried to go after others and tried to
move against Schultz and Weinberger who
had been against the arms for hostages
it's very tragic it's you know there was
an indictment of Weinberger for notes
that he hadn't revealed and and there
was a pardon going into the end of the
Bush administration it it's it's tragic
that that again your your story on an
independent council there was a model in
the beginning and then I think went
beyond the bounds later than that is is
a morality tale in itself the final
chapter in my book is Reagan in history
I saw him at his best I I saw him at at
NATO when I was ambassador after the
Geneva meeting and he at the Geneva
meeting and I wasn't there you know he
the handlers wanted him to be with
Gorbachev for about 10 or 15 minutes and
he went on for over an hour and this
transformational president who Neustadt
compares to Roosevelt in this regard had
a certain intuitive sense before any of
his cabinet members that he could do
business with Gorbachev he decided that
Gorbachev was in part trapped by this
economic system we had stood fast on and
counter deployed Pershing missiles we'd
blocked him at that door and he sort of
was stuck and Reagan with his civility
connected with him and he believed in
trust but verify and one of the great
moments of human history began in that
meeting where the tide of history was
turned
towards the end of the Cold War and it
took two years for it to take place in
in this transformation of leadership
which we saw both internationally and
domestically a new stat says compares
him to Roosevelt who was a
transformational leader both in the new
deal and in winning the world war two
and he said you know he was the last
Roosevelt Democrat after all he voted
for FDR four times he memorized his
speeches he thought he was the greatest
president Max kampelman it's not in my
book cause he told me this story our
strategic negotiated that he was in with
a meeting with with Reagan with the with
Shelton and Weinberger and there had
been a move up on Capitol Hill to to
bring in a congressional Advisory Group
the very thing by the way that Wilson
should have done on the Versailles
Treaty and and the two Kelley Cameron
officials were very much against this
everybody was very much against it but
Shultz said two to kampelman ah but I'll
have you in the meeting and you can
speak up and he spoke up and he said mr.
president I think this is what we should
do and explain why and the president
said max I agree with you so as they
walked out I guess the cabinet members
not being happy in and present rate said
max hang back here and he said with
others out of the room said max you know
you're you know the only two people in
the room that have voted Democratic and
Reagan had many sides of him on
Roosevelt Henry Stimson his great army
war secretary said he had a grasshopper
mind he hopped from suggestions to his
suggestions he was intuitive
transformational leaders automatically
are that way so they've got to have good
managers below them to transform
they're visions into road what Lincoln
had was a genius and he had both but
seldom do you find both combined in one
Jimmy Carter and Herbert Hoover two
outstanding people great character were
engineers over just with engineers this
afternoon so I don't take this the wrong
way but they they were so absorbed in
details that they could never convey the
big picture to the public those big
intuitive things like the book bling in
some way you got it right some way you
recognized and could move with the tide
of history so I think that in the first
period of the Reagan presidency you had
Jim Baker we were just at the Baker
Institute and with this with such
enormous ability in a combination of me
sand and Deaver and gergan and then in
the latter part you had Howard Baker and
and Kendu Burstein and it was only in
this middle period where he was so
poorly served I think that I I just like
people that read from their own books
but I'm gonna read from my last dislike
myself and I'm gonna read from the last
paragraph of my book Reagan's appraisal
well no I'm not I'm a little ahead I've
got two other things to say but first I
want to take Reagan's own appraisal of
himself I never thought of myself as a
great man just a man committed the great
ideas you know he was not an ideologue
he was an Edmund Burke conservative
Edmund Burke hated the ideologues of the
French Revolution he could be very
practical he had a conservative
philosophy but was very practical
understanding the human factors
he was inclusive he had these three
important Democrats kampelman Paul Nitsa
Mike Mansfield is ambassador he was an
inclusive leader and when we got to his
funeral I think that's why the people so
mourned him that that unity in America
that he contributed to that led to the
winning of the Cold War Ted Kennedy said
speaking at Yale it would be foolish to
deny that his success in commander to
deny that his success in command of
public ideas Ronald Reagan may have
forgotten names but never his goals he
was a great communicator not simply
because of his personality or his
teleprompter but mostly because he had
something to communicate and the back of
my book if you buy it and I hope some of
you will the first picture on the book
is when I first arrived he's back from
the hospital
he's down Gorbachev is up he looked so
poor that Nancy Reagan would not let the
picture be released on the back we're
leaving three months my staff the part
of them that would leave with me were in
there and I said mr. president Benham
I'm so we're all so indebted to you for
being able to serve you and he said no
David I'm indebted to you for finding me
not guilty
well of course my job wasn't if I had
him not he found himself not guilty but
his self humor his humility made him a
person who could be a uniter and not a
divider
so here's the final paragraph a poor
manager indeed but what America needed
at this time in history was not a good
manager to effectively maintain the
status quo still scarred by Vietnam
frustrated by an inflationary economy
and waging an old and unending Cold War
America needed a leader who could see
beyond the murky
present to bold new visions it needed a
leader with transforming ideas and the
ability to communicate then a leader
with good will and incredible optimism
to attract others to accept his vision
of the future it needed a leader with
character to stand up after a fall to
restore the integrity of the presidency
and to gracefully leave office with the
end of the Cold War inside I think at
this time in history America needed
Ronald Reagan thank you very much
[Applause]
I gather by your applause you agree with
that conclusion but I doubt you would be
here if you didn't agree with it anyway
so who would be first in making a
comment or a question yes ma'am I think
they preferred that the people with the
cameras like that
sir you had a list of presidents who
faced problems and then just made them
worse like Nixon in your opinion is
there another president besides Reagan
who did a good job of taking a problem
and then digging himself out of it well
I I think to a lesser extent Eisenhower
with Khrushchev had had a low period and
you know he had had a health problem
before that that was not to to this
extent and I I don't I can't give you as
dramatic a case as Reagan where the hole
was so deep and the the decision to get
out so dramatic and that that's a sad
conclusion because as I say we do have
these cases where they got into a hole
and and really didn't get out I'd like
to thank you first off on behalf of all
the students here at am for coming and
taking time to speak to us this evening
my question more of I grew up in the in
the early 80s and basically the
iran-contra affair was something that
kind of was a big part of my upbringing
and how I viewed government my question
for you would be and your upbringing in
the late 20s and early 30s what were
this kind of events and
things going on in government that kind
of shaped your view of how you should
deal with these kind of situations or
what influences in government helped you
come to the leadership I don't want you
to dwell on my upbringing in the 20s to
mind but you know age is relative when
when I came back in special counselor
Ronald Reagan was 75 76 you know I would
tell myself you know I'm dealing with an
older person I don't view it that way
anymore I think 75 John but I grew up in
a great age I grew up when the storm
clouds were arising in Europe and the
war was coming and we had a president
who had led us through the New Deal and
I came from an East Tennessee Republican
family and didn't fully appreciate that
kind of leadership and then a year from
the war he said to Harry Hopkins now
we've got to get ready for the war
Hitler's got to be stopped
majority of American public's not with
us we've got all these isolationist and
he said we're gonna change entirely and
you know what he did in this epiphany of
his he had done the soak the rich speech
in 1935 hitting all of these Republicans
and he says to Harry Hopkins we're gonna
go out and get those Republicans we're
gonna get the head of US Steel and all
these guys to organize
and there was this brilliant engineer
scientist Vanover Bush that didn't
particularly at the Carnegie Institute
that didn't particularly like Roosevelt
because he thought he would regulate
science he seduces him he says you're
gonna organize the universities and the
labs of the country to win the war
through science and then he said Wendell
Willkie my opponent I want you to run a
mission over there to see Churchill
this was great leadership in unifying
the country and I grew up with that kind
of leadership with a country so
different than the Vietnam period that
was totally United and our service
people I fought in Korea my fighting was
nothing compared to these people that
fought for four years so I I grew up
with that kind of inspiration of people
that had done the impossible
and the leader was a person who had
paralysis and couldn't walk
inconceivable and then we moved into the
Cold War with Truman and the Truman plan
and the unity that he produced and then
General Eisenhower who was an icon of
mine I had gotten out of the Regular
Army at that time and come to to
Washington and I held him in all so you
know those were my inspirations that
were great inspirations and that that
was my learning experience and I still
think that that today that we can all
learn a great deal we're not enough of a
unified nation there's not enough
sacrifice shared sacrifice for the war
on terror I'm deeply involved with this
with Homeland Security
we've got our proposals we're we're not
building the bipartisan coalition's that
we need with regard to to Iraq and we
the the Mark Twain said history doesn't
repeat itself but it can rhyme and we
don't want that situation to rhyme with
with Vietnam so I grew up in this
inspirational period of leadership that
went out and incorporated the best
talent to get things done and that's not
new to American history that's what
happened in the Constitutional
Convention the best talent of people
that couldn't agree the wedge issues
with those people in the Constitutional
Convention was greater than today they
created something that they didn't think
was that good at the time and later it
was sacred scriptures so that was sort
of the inspiration that that came came
to me
sorry make that speech anyway sorry got
wound up
yes sir pressures well well I think
those those pressures are unbelievable
the the you know we we think if a major
decision is being made now all the
president thinks about that days at one
decision and down at the the LBJ library
they were talking to me about some
exercises that they've got going to the
day that the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution
President Johnson made that they've
looked at all the things before him that
that we think that's the only thing he's
thinking about that he realizes that
this is a terribly important decision
and you know you're sort of running from
one thing to another and those strains
on a president or enormous Woodrow
Wilson who and it was such a brilliant
intellect but was was so rigid in
doctrinaire and that even occurred in
his his fight with Dean West at
Princeton but you know if you get too
much presidential rigidity you you've
got to this is where Reagan and and and
Roosevelt and some others have had such
ability you you've got to have strategic
direction but you've got to stay close
to reality to make changes Lincoln was
the greatest at this it he started out
with Emancipation Proclamation we lost
the war it was not until after Antietam
that he could make his grand maneuver so
these enormous pressures and if a
president is too rigid those are going
to build up too much and this is why
you've got to watch out that the Oval
Office doesn't become too much of a
bubble like it did under Woodrow Wilson
and that their new circumstance that
call for new decisions because Johnson
got caught in in the Vietnam situation
so I think that aging process becomes
takes place with any president because
of the nature of it but is accelerated
if we're you you've got a president that
that doesn't grasp a new situation and
and when new moves are made to relieve
some of those pressures and to get
history moving in his direction rather
than against him yes sir dr. Rob sherry
thank you very much for Yero incisive
and inspiring talk it has been a treat
listening to you I have a question for
you on the end of the Cold War and the
ultimate breakup of the Soviet Union but
first I'd like to preface it with a
brief historical note I believe the
turning point in the out is final
outcome of the Cold War probably took
place sometime around 1959 in a
classroom at Columbia University at
witch University Columbia come here it
was a professor of history the taught a
class in American history class that
included Alexander Yakovlev I'm sure you
know of him probably you know him he
passed away several days ago
but during that study of course of study
that yakovlev was exposed to
I believe the ideals of American
democracy were implanted were seared in
his mind and conscience
Yakovlev later turned out to be the
intellectual Godfather of Gorbachev when
he returned to the Soviet Union after
attending Columbia he advanced in the
ranks of the Communist Party and he was
disliked intensely by the old Bolsheviks
so he sent basically to exile and
Canada's and a passenger there and when
Michael Gorbachev was visit the Canada
they had some rather heart-to-heart
talks about the system they had the
Soviet Union the both recognized it was
no good and he had to be changed and
later on who knew yuck of life and
Gorbachev visited New York The New York
Times had a front page headlined with
your college pictures say it's up to the
effect perhaps the walls are not exact
but the people will tell us how they
wish to be governed now if one did not
know who said it and won't ask to gas
the gas might have been something like
Thomas Jefferson or some one of the
founding fathers of this country I said
that was a profound development in what
was happening within the Soviet Union
and he did refer correctly that the
process is what were in progress at the
time of the Reagan administration in
Washington there was a collateral set of
processes going on within the Soviet
Union and I think yakovlev and Gorbachev
were determined to change things
and that was manifested in part at least
by the glass recent perestroika and
yakovlev versus the architect of those
well certainly there is no question that
the influence of President Reagan in
dealing with Gorbachev and others for
that Martin was very important in the
final outcome of the Cold War but I
wonder if you care to give us your
insight of how important or how
instrumental I should say was the the
internal processes in the Soviet Union
at the time for Gorbachev was in office
and Margaret Thatcher was the one first
to say that we can do business who was
mr. Goldwyn crying can you give us some
insight on the other side of the fence
well I I think what you say is very
important you made a very important
statement I had a conversation with
Jankovic once and I'm very very
impressed by him in his role but you
know when I was assistant secretary of
state dealing with the Congress one of
the jobs I had was saving Radio Free
europe/radio Liberty and I didn't know
much about him if the CIA funding was
being cut off and by the way they were
saved with a deal that I made with the
Democratic majority leader who was
against the radios but didn't think they
should be cut off the way some senators
wanted to and then when I went back to
CSIS I got word from the White House
they wanted me to be the chairman of the
board for international broadcasting
since I was an expert on this subject I
didn't know anything about it but I even
boned up on and even wrote a book on it
before I was through but I became very
impressed because we had all the
samizdat papers in Munich and were
broadcasting back those were the papers
of the dissidents and were broadcasting
back to them what the dissidents and the
thinkers in the in the soviet union were
thinking and in
and 80% of the population listened to
Radio Free Europe because you could get
the best economic news what was really
going on in the hierarchy there required
we found out from our intelligence a
summary every morning of what the
economists at Munich had said so the
what you're the you know my speech
naturally oversimplifies a very dramatic
role that Reagan played and he he was
able to play it because he was perceived
as a hardliner who could make this move
but you see where Reagan here he would
agree with you very much because he
called the Soviet Union the evil empire
he talked about the system he didn't
believe the people were evil Reagan had
a spirituality to him that was key to
his makeup when Reagan was tempted to
assassin and Reagan was in the hospital
he prayed for the assassin so he saw
Gorbachev as a person and decided that
he wanted to break out of this system
and Reagan gave him the revolving door
and both could move only so much at one
time so you know there are all sorts of
things in the group I talked to in
Houston john paul ii played such a key
role when he said if they moved into to
poland he would go to poland his native
Poland but Eisenhower in setting up the
United States Information Agency felt
that the the role of ideas ultimately
would be key more important than the
armies and navies and the yearning for
freedom and the fact that this system in
in the Soviet Union
was not working but you had to develop
the way out and Reagan and Gorbachev
then became the facilitators of that
turn yes sir
regarding the current situation in
Washington with the investigation into
the leak of the CIA agents identity how
big I don't know what's gonna happen oh
I'm just gonna ask how big of a hole do
you think that puts President Bush in
and how would you rate his handling of
the affair so well I think if there if
there were charges and we don't know
that that that indictments are brought
to bear it's going to be a very serious
problem and I you know I I think it'd be
good for him to look at some of these
other presidents and Reagan being one
how how to handle situations like that I
mean it's it's the situation he's
dealing with is not comparable to
iran-contra but the principles are the
are the the same and I you know I I
think I when you're in a hole I believe
in getting fresh outside advice by the
way it's very important to get the right
source of advice and not the wrong
source of advice
Bill Clinton Turner to Morris and that
was a terrible mistake he should have
gotten Lloyd Cutler an esteemed lawyer
in Washington and councillor de Carter
to come in and and give him some advice
and the this the president this
president does have great challenges in
Iraq and the the Guard and the reserves
and the financial picture and the twin
deficits in and we got to healthcare
calls so he's got an array of I don't
know of a time you know other than in
World War two where we've been more
challenged and I just believe in those
that you
go get the best brains and and and try
to try to try to put them together and
you know how you do that is is depends
upon getting the right people but he you
know we are probably at a turning point
in history because we've got so much to
stake and I by the way I think condi
rice is Secretary of State is doing an
extraordinary job and and and Karen
Hughes over there whither and we've we
we can to to plagiarize Lincoln we can
nobly save or meanly lose a great cause
in the Middle East people can argue
rightly have differences of views on how
we got into Iraq I don't know many
differences of views in Washington that
if we don't handle it successfully that
the consequences will be far more severe
than than Vietnam so we're we're at a
historic point where President Bush can
go on to new heights and great
achievements as Reagan came out and and
went on to the end of the Cold War and
the the the vision of the Middle East is
is extraordinary but history's not spun
out and we're at a tipping point in in
many ways
maybe Roman we're all questioned out
that was the old days I are there any
final questions
I guess now you've been a great audience
and I think you all are your questions
have been a family
[Applause]